Curiosity is one of humankind's most beautiful traits.
We want to know as much as possible about the world around us.
But to satisfy our need to know about the world around us,...
...our eyes just aren't good enough anymore.
With the power of engineering, we have been able to take a look at worlds...
...hidden inside and outside the narrow range of our human senses.
We can take a look at the smallest life forms, our own cells and even molecules...
...using electron microscopes.
Complex machines that make invisible things visible,...
...so we can discover worlds inside of worlds, inside of worlds, inside of worlds.
Discoveries at the nanolevel have changed how we perceive the universe around us forever...
...and led to countless discoveries.
On the other hand, just a few centuries ago, engineers developed powerful tools of science...
...that gave us the ability to look deep into space and spot countless wonders of the universe.
Later came spacecraft and satellites.
The Hubble Telescope was one of these wonders of technology.
Without it, we would never have known...
...that our galaxy is one of billions in an enormous universe.